the Catalonian city of Girona home to
the world's best restaurant as salar de
can roca 60 employees are on hand to
cater to 55 guests it costs 135 euros to
dine here a steal when you consider how
sublime the food is world's best
restaurant 2013 is el celler de can roca
a month ago british magazine restaurant
listed the 50 best restaurants in the
world a jury of nine hundred
international professionals dubbed the
three spanish brothers john joseph and
jordi raka the world's best chefs what
that look that what ever love anyone
move it we're floating on a cloud we're
very happy about the award nothing like
having a leading role in avant-garde
cuisine is a big responsibility la
cocina de una manera la voz en el agua
now it's time for the winners to show us
what they're made up Joanne Rocca is
preparing one of his most popular dishes
these prawns heads are being dehydrated
to make them crispy while the bodies are
quickly grilled over charcoal algae and
plankton are added for a taste of the
sea tharaka brothers seek to awaken
diners emotions and memories their
methods are often very avant-garde
nirala desta lamos para buscar we
distill earth for example to extract the
aroma of moist earth we're trying to
evoke feelings such as melancholy or
nostalgia but I reprove a feedlot year
this aroma reminds us of the walks we
used to take in the forest after a rain
shower or estas por ESO porque cercanos
cuando acaba de yo where it all began
next door in the bar run by their
parents an establishment that's still
going strong the three sons started
helping out as children and by 1986 two
of them were ready to go it alone their
logo is designed to symbolize teamwork
today Joe on his head chef Jordi takes
care of desserts and Joseph is in charge
of the wine your brothers as long as the
easiest thing in the world for us we've
always worked like this and don't know
any other way it's very natural coming
at the ronald spain is regaining its
reputation as the home of world-class
cuisine el celler de can roca isn't the
only Spanish restaurant to shine in San
Sebastian the moog earth and the Arzak
also made it into the top 10 Spain did
better than any other country this year
journalist Julia Perez thinks the secret
is the lively exchange of ideas between
Spanish chefs she's been watching the
scene developed for more than 20 years
have you not put the cooks here are very
open with each other and happy to share
their food and research findings it's
been an asset to the whole culinary
movement in Spain he'll totally
emollient apolinario celebrity chef
Ferran Adria is a pioneer of molecular
cooking in Spain his restaurant el bulli
was named the best restaurant in the
world no less than five times before it
closed two years ago many of the world's
top chefs honed their craft at elderly
including John bracha in 1989 you know
that I bank you know Tom escaped before
you were anticipating the beginning of a
revolution it was a phase of creativity
and nonconformity big instead we wanted
to think freely about cooking beyond the
boundaries of academic orthodox cooking
emporia una fear taco fina academica
orto dosa
and it turned out they were onto
something the rocket brothers are now
faded as stars but it's a long way to
eat at the best restaurant in the world
weekend tables are booked a year in
advance